bene tutti ragazzi e per questo video
sono fa vigenti ci siamo trovati su
saint rock tv che sarebbe 4 io sono già
morto prendi parte non sono fatta hang
on gaza
non mi ricordo già più come si gioca ad
è passata una settimana e ciò
l'alzheimer ma questo lo sappiamo già
porca eva non parcheggiate dove potreste
darmi fastidio anche perché potrei
spostarvi la macchina con un calcio che
cazzo spara fao ragazzi si conosce
passato dio santo sono vivo soltanto
presunti rinfaccia ma sono più
[Musica]
non mi romperà sicuramente più [ __ ]
questo gioco con continua non aver senso
io continuo a giocarlo e non capisco
perché ci metti ad investire le mie troy
e comunque ragazzi su centro perché
voglio fare ciò che non ho fatto l'altra
volta che sarebbe l'ammissione on the
same same chris marrs che non ho fatto
l'ultima volta quindi devo tenermi per
non cazzeggiare perché mi viene a
cazzeggiare ogni cinque minuti
[Musica]
la madonna una storia che racconteremo
ai bambini invece che la storia della
befana milizia che ben addobbato è
proprio la nave gol e quelle calze
carino sì perché in realtà la nave
proprio in tema natalizio c'è per carità
senza boxer
ma no perché a [ __ ] babbo natale è
brutto
oddio cosa succede chi è questo mio
babbo mortale leader militare della mia
epoca babbo mortale ragazzi dobbiamo
salvare babbo natale che è stato
intrappolato nono zio dimmi che non stai
facendo quello che so ti prego che sta
il bello dei votanti fu fatta non ama la
macchina perfetta gara perché se non ci
arrivò mai più alla stellina e norah
jones a te non ti fa centrali stavo
scherzando fai quello che vuoi ma qui
facendo il ciclo e ragazze non c'è verso
fanno quello che vuoi bambini cattivi in
cielo guardate il vostro cupo destino
mirate quello è stato un errore fatale
vi punirà babbo mortale questo e barbo
mortale che cazzo di fucile di merda mi
spiegate perchè il mio fucile sbarazzo
lette da zucchero è morite moret fango
la browser me senti babbo ecco è questo
sarebbe proprio morta che brutto lo dico
sempre ai bambini che certi giocatori
sono pericolosi ok sembri più non sa che
ho vestito da babbo natale e che babbo
natale zio ragazzi sappiate che nella
vita io sono riuscito a portare babbo
natale immagini non possono mica dirlo a
tutti sta cosa c'è una roba particolare
con babbo ti stai divertendo
e bubble ti diverti e bubble bobble fai
volare babbo ti stai divertendo ma
poverino tanto natale è già passato mi è
già balzato i regali quindi puoi anche
morire per grazie all'invio ragazzi mi
hanno ridato le mie armi allora io
parcheggio così ragazzi tranquilli c'è
non è che ho sbagliato
no no fuori da eva sono morto questa è
un'arma questa cos'era quella staccata
di prima fa eco la spada
chi è attaccato la spada bravo zio bravo
zio ha ucciso un omino di zenzero così
sarà contento l'uomo focaccina comunque
ragazzi ho trovato il proiettore credo
che sia questo sempre che cosa me ne
devo fare mano il filo vero babbo che
eva ti spacco la slitta giusto per
ripicca scritto che scrivo più che
scotta ma la mia volontà non si cappotta
perché questo qua è fumato ma ha fumato
sentito zio la neve te la tiri dal naso
serviti aiuto ma chi è che sta parlando
aiuta sidco l'antenna anche perché
faccia di mi devi mettere la tua lingua
devo mettere la lingua che cazzo dici ad
essere volgare di fronte a babbo natale
va bene dai
facciamo che metto la lingua sulla ok
cenno il proiettore ci siamo ragazzi lo
accendono luci di babbo natale ci siamo
facebook sarebbe lui devo uccidere la
morte è durato un secondo alzate alzate
finisci vanno mortale non lo faccio
oddio è fortissimo poi sconfiggere baba
mortale con la cattiveria perché lo
rende più forte e allora cosa vuoi che
faccia abbiamo al polo nord
ragazzi ho sempre desiderato vederlo ma
non così però la vera intenzione di
consegnare bombe e armi ai bambini al
posto delle solite bambole
mi chiedo è più contento sono alla
versione scherzando ok dai dai dai dai
dai dai lo fermiamo noi non prendiamo
noi
io posso la cosa bella è che ci sono
oddio oddio ti strappo il cuore anche se
non sei fatto di zenzero cassino volo
vorrei dire ma mi sto salvando un natale
per l'anno prossimo perché se non ci
fossi io
e cosa vendi nel negozio di babbo
togliti e cosa fa bravo folletto farti
valere fatti valere bravo bravo
grandissime forte ragazzi è forte lo
vedo carico ai babbo fa qualcosa fa
qualcosa nato a vita inutile fai
qualcosa
bravo questo volevo maledizione spiegami
perchè ti sei attivato solo adesso
deficiente neri ha attivato le difese di
emergenza vai nelle stalle o lecca la
porta ma perché le cose se il bello è
che te la dà proprio come scelta di
leccare la porta perché tu potresti
anche farlo però ci metti sei anni va bè
metti fuori uso la renna eccola cece
perfetto lo faccio subito mi sto
togliendo delle cose dal culo ok questa
cosa non è proprio ortodossa però buon
natale cara
so che desiderare tanto infatti infilare
un braccio nel deretano prenatale
siamo ragazzi eccolo qua bellissimo
verde fossi con i regali di babbo natale
ho sempre desiderato vedere lutero dov'è
la mia playstation che ho chiesto quando
avevo 10 anni stranzi stiamo per entrare
dentro a bello e così questi sono i
regali per i bambini fantasma solo
bambina che ordinano a barbie è certo
punto scarpe si trova un m 4 a 1 cioè
ragazzi da fare invidia solid snake è
proprio una roba c'è della serie non ci
troveranno mai fare con contiamo
sottocoperta cui dirmi che la tiffany
babbo natale c'è un mitra uzi anni e
melo portare in te è incazzata incazzata
l'avrei mai immaginato che la voglia di
babbo natale forse così figari e sto
facendo ragazzi tutto con lanciarazzi
che ammazza in un colpo quindi ci metto
un secondo politi zia togliti hanno
fatto un feto è tutto a posto
cerchi regalino aprire che bello ragazzi
sempre sognato
cioè spara ai dischi di skrillex tarola
c'è un'arma che spara musica
c'è e geniale comunque va a bossi e
wayne upgrade che faccia p danno
dovresti fare un'arma che sparì cd di
gigi d'alessio a quello fa male oggi è
stato così via mazzate la tipa dietro
questa la scena più trash che io abbia
mai visto una storia di videogame falsa
sia falsa fargli colo madama che su
letta e ci da laboratori sono fuori ma
non abbiamo vinto perché stanno
scappando comunque devo salire sulla
slitta ragazzi perché devo andare a
uccidere definitivamente babbo mortale
credo posso guidarla io ti prego bubble
una cosa ti cioè la madonna ragazze
diventerei min civili a meno che tu non
riesca a portare l'allegria tra la gente
prima della mezzanotte regala missione
finale dobbiamo riuscirci ovvio 7 minuti
e 57 forza va beh devo andare a
consegnare i regali idonei si consegnava
macello e già la gente mi spara addosso
ma il ragazzino a domanda come fanno i
bambini che vivono a new york
in questi grattacieli a ricevere i
regali di babbo come fa arrivare babbo
natale in casa
bene così bene così forza spacca i culi
mammamia contavo quest'uomo scusate
ragazzi mi fate un favore se vi lascio
parcheggiata la macchina ma pulitanò
hanno voglia fancazzo city pan di
zenzero idioti piccolo bambino che se
aspettando i regali per questo natale se
ti affacci alla finestra vedi zio favi
che ti regala la roba croce gente che
palle la cosa più bella visto gioco sono
le musiche perché in una roba così che
c'è disastro cesta musica qualche qual è
il senso sei felice tu lo sai battista
dove gli interni stanno sparando
spiegano i gay
ok barry klien no mi chiamo mancato
rischio è quasi mezzanotte di muoverti
ho capito che il ciclo zia però e con le
giuste tempistiche impieghi e ci metto
già un anno e mezzo
eccoveli con la tua se non mi avessi
scassato i trequarti di di birillo a
quest'ora sarei vigo invece no devo
battere babbo mortale siamo tutti qua
c'è anche sciami fantastico bravo zio
balla questo regalo protette l'ora che
era una sciarpa solo che sei morto
quindi va beh hai fatto il bravo
quest'anno a prendi questo ragazzo il
regalo e la [ __ ] eccolo qua tutto
per voi ragazzi tutto per voi un regalo
in quattro così risparmiamo ce l'ho
fatta rallegrati anche tu
vogliono fare oddio mica lech in diablo
c'è da star carneficina ok come lo
uccido è ancora si muove manco fosse la
lince guarda li tieni babbo so che tu
hai fatto lo stronzo ma te lo regalo lo
stesso afferra il dono della moglie di
babbo natale babbo è tutto tuo
afferra donadi c anni e ci siamo quasi
di ferimenti o finito se ce l'ho fatta
[ __ ] va portale ditemi qual è il
senso
la madonna esagerazione zio hai salvato
il natale frate bravo a sia accesa anche
l'altro quindi a posto poi a goderti la
di girare il natale perché glielo sta
dicendo a 1 che ha ucciso delle persone
e la cosa piu non sense io mi ha mai
giocato cosa succede adesso giocando coi
miei amici certo così sarò messo nella
lista dei buoni e bello vedere di un
gioco serio una volta tanto questo è per
te e la testa di un uomo morto ecco
perfetto di che contenta tutti i vicini
che facciamo una foto di gruppo e la
mettiamo sulla copertina di facebook per
me tu sei perfetto severe se emozionato
bellissimo ciao ciao siete stati bravi a
babbo natale sasso charme non c'è niente
da fare la fine non ho mai giocato a una
roba più seria in vita mia non ho
veramente dubbi sfida sbloccata farfan
vip babbo natale certo poi guardi i miei
video e capisci che effettivamente di
bip ce ne sono ben pochi che sia ragazzi
era questo che voglio fare quando
avviato per la prima volta se entro
quando l'ultima volta ho passeggiato
solo che mi sono preso troppo nei
cassetti però che la vita vi sia
piaciuto ragazzi cosa sento se vi è
piaciuta soprattutto è un mi piace
sappiate che se da via serrati il natale
sarà ancora disponibile sarà solo per
merito di parigi e quindi non ringrazia
temi l'ho fatto volentieri sono serviti
gli scrittori ci vediamo il prossimo vi
do ragazzi e buon natale anche se sono
passate tre settimane forse se gabella
ragazzi